bienvenue à paris autochtone c'est
mélissa mollen depuis cette semaine j'ai
reçu une question de louis qui me pose
la question
les autochtones ne peut-il réellement
pas de taxes d'impôts et d'électricité
louis cette question là elle est
tellement vieille et elle a une vie
d'elle-même parce que ont ils répondu
plusieurs fois mais ça s'est mélangée
avec des concepts et ça l'a vu l'effet
de créer une légende urbaine qui veut
que les profanations on est pour rien
pas de taxes d'impôts pas d'électricité
il ya une réalité c'est celle que si tu
es un indien est inscrit sous la loi sur
les indiens et tous deux suivis sur une
réserve
c'est vrai que tu ne paies pas de textes
de services sur les produits qu'ils
achètent sur la réserve
c'est vrai aussi que t'as pas d'impôts
qui sont au prix sur ton salaire que tu
gagnes sur la réserve
mais aussitôt sort de la réserve et que
tu n'es pas dans un territoire
autochtone tu paie des impôts tu paie
des taxes moi si je gagne mon salaire à
montréal présentement je paie de l'impôt
et s'il essaie de ne pas le pays je peux
te dire que comme n'importe quel autre
québécois ils vont venir me chercher
assez vite pour ce qui est des hydro
électricité c'est la même chose on paie
l'hydroélectricité il ya des fois des
ententes territoriales qui peuvent être
faites en une nation et l'hydro parce
qu'ils vont faire d'exploitation
d'hydroélectricité sur leur territoire
parce qu'il est d'aider les lignes à
haute tension qui vont passer sur le
territoire autochtone mais ces ententes
à ce fonds avec la communauté et
beaucoup de communautés paient aussi
leur électricité sinon ils se font
couper comme n'importe qui d'autre
je dirais que si jamais on payait pas
notre hydroélectricité qu'on avait de
l'électricité gratuite
autant qu on en voudrait les réserves
seraient illuminés comme des sapins à
noël c'est paul quoi c'est la raison
pourquoi cette question leur revient si
souvent c'est que les gens ont pris en
pet qu'on avait eu un avantage est
presque d'une personne nantis on le sait
que dans les communautés autochtones on
n'est pas les nations les plus nantis au
canada mais la raison pourquoi on a été
exempt de taxes et d'impôts sont des
réserves c'est quelqu'un on était sur
les réserves justement on était
considérés comme des enfants aux yeux de
la loi on était sous tutelle donc des
personnes sous tutelle ne paieront pas
de taxe parce que ce sont des enfants
dont ils ont accès à des services tels
que les soins de santé sur la réserve
qui sont liées au fait qu'ils sont des
intérêts inscrits pour tout ce qui est
des détails de l'exemption taxe de des
fois des fraudes qui sont faites avec
des cartes des fausses cas d'edel 1 faut
que tu ailles dans les nouvelles tu vas
voir c'est toujours d'écho park mais
dans l'ensemble c'est vraiment pas une
réalité comme quand on roule sur l'or
puis quand on reçoit un chèque parce
qu'on est des uns et des inscrits ou ben
parce qu'on paye pas de taxes et
d'impôts
il ya vraiment une réalité qu'on en paie
et si jamais on venait un jour à ne plus
avoir la loi sur les indiens
probablement que un système de taxes et
d'impôts s'impliquerait dans la vie se
réservent pour justement payer pour les
services qui autrefois qu'on était sous
tutelle a été pris en charge par le
fédéral mais faut pas oublier si on
enlève la tutelle on redonne des
territoires qui sont présentement encore
sous la main du fédéral du provincial
est-ce que c'est plus payant de nous
garder sous tutelle c'est l'impression
que ça donne
puisque la loi sur les aider a pas
encore été enlevés et n'a pas été encore
négocié avec les communautés pour être
retirée comme projet de loi dans les
projets des excuses comme loi donc
j'espère avoir même effleuré un peu la
question pour toi
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
questions n'hésitez pas à partager ses
vidéos je vous souhaite une très belle
semaine